remember what um solzhenitsyn said bless
you prison i mean great imagine he was
he suffered horribly in prison but he
said bless you prison because it brought
him to that salvation it brought him out
of himself and there's no
necessary
proof that if you undertake to suffer
for the truth that
you won't pay the final price
the problem is
you're going to pay a price for the
alternative too and so will everybody
else
[Music]
hello everyone i'm here today with
rod drear a senior editor at the
american conservative he's a veteran of
three decades of magazine and newspaper
journalism
rod has written two previous new york
times bestsellers the benedict option
and the little way of ruthie lemming as
well as crunchy cons
and how dante can save your life today
we are posed to discuss his newest book
live not by lies inspired not least by
the great alexander solzhenitsyn author
of the gulag archipelago
the book that helped bring down the evil
soviet empire
good to meet you rod it's been a long
time coming and i'm looking forward to
discussing your book
yeah thank you jordan it has been a long
time coming because you of all people in
north america
are an expert on totalitarianism and so
i've been very eager to see what your
take on the book is and to have a
fruitful discussion with you about it
yeah so the title live not by lies it's
a it's a lovely phrase um a catchy
phrase too for what that's worth and i
suppose that indicates some poetic
genius do you want to talk a little bit
about why you picked that title where it
came from and and also what motivated
you to write the book
sure well the title comes from an essay
that alexander solzhenitsyn sent out to
his followers just before the soviets
expelled him in 1974.
and in the essay he told
the people who followed him that look we
can't go out on red square and say
exactly what we think we don't have that
option in totalitarian russia
but what we can do is refuse to say what
we do not think this is the power we
have to refuse to speak lies or to
refuse to ascent to lies where they are
spoken around us
and i i think that that is a very
valuable lesson for us today living
under very different conditions
you know in uh in the 2020s but we are
living in a time of a different kind of
totalitarianism
and that brings us to why
the the book why i began to write the
book the genesis of the book
around 2015
i received a phone call from a man a
physician at the mayo clinic
who said listen i have to tell somebody
this i have to tell some journalist this
he said his elderly mother lives with
him and his wife there and she had
immigrated to america after she was
released from prison and communist
czechoslovakia she had spent four years
in prison there and was tortured for
being a vatican spy why did they call
her vatican spy because she refused
their order to stop going to church
well the lady came to america she
married she started a family but now at
the end of her life she was telling her
son
son the things i see happening in
america today remind me of what i left
behind
well what was she talking about she's
talking about the fact that people are
terrified to say what they really think
she was talking about how people could
lose their businesses or lose their jobs
simply for having the quote unquote
wrong opinion she was talking about how
mobs were generated by for ideological
reasons to drive people to the margins
of society she was talking about the way
language is being falsified in service
of an ideological agenda and she was
talking about the way that not only the
state but also private institutions are
making people think of themselves in
terms of group identities not individual
rights and that all of this seemed to be
part of a totalitarian mindset
well i thought jordan that what this old
lady said was kind of outrageous you
know my mother is old she watches a lot
of cable news she's afraid of things too
but then i began to ask people whenever
i would meet them on at conferences or
when i travel
if i would find out that they're from
the soviet bloc they came to the west
from the soviet bloc i would simply ask
them are the things you're seeing happen
here in north america consonant with
what you left behind jordan every single
one of them said yes
and if you talk to them long enough they
would be so angry that americans
wouldn't believe them because we just
don't think it could happen here and i
began the more began to talk to them the
more i began to realize that
the cause of this or the basic cause of
this is that our idea of totalitarianism
depends on the cold war it comes from
stalinism it comes from george orwell's
1984.
in which the all-powerful state forced
totalitarian ideology on people by
making them afraid and by inflicting
pain and terror on them but we don't
have that now we don't have gulags we
don't have secret police yet anyway we
don't have bread lines and all the
things that we associate with the soviet
union so why is this totalitarianism
well i came to understand that this is a
softer form and a different form a form
that has more to do with aldous huxley's
brave new world than with orwell's 1984.
it is a totalitarianism built on comfort
and status and well-being
and we can't really see it because our
we're looking to the past to tell us
what totalitarianism is totalitarianism
is but these people these emigrates who
lived through it
they sense it they are our canaries in
the coal mine and we better listen to
them so i wrote the book to not only
talk about what they were seeing
happening in our time and place that
reminded them of totalitarianism but
also i traveled to central europe and to
russia to talk to people who didn't
emigrate people who stayed behind to
resist and i wanted to find out from
them what should we in the west do to
prepare ourselves for what is to come
and to live lives of integrity rooted in
the truth and rooted in courage
so i was just in eastern europe
talking to
people in romania and hungary and
albania and estonia other eastern
european countries
and
it's clear that
people there who battled the communists
for years
and younger people who know of the
history of communist totalitarianism in
eastern europe look at the west and
think the same way that the emigres that
you described are thinking that the
web of ideas that
increasingly possesses let's say the
radical left and is spreading into the
culture at large bears an eerie and
uncanny resemblance to the system of
ideas that swamped the soviet states and
so much of the world during the cold war
and the eastern europeans are very
apprehensive about that and i would say
for good reason
um
i i also so that's that's an interesting
commentary on the opinions of people who
have actually moved to the west the
people who've lived through this see the
same thing happening again and then on
your comment about the top-down versus
bottom-up model of totalitarianism
might have been i wouldn't say exactly a
flaw with orwell's 1984 because it's
hard you're hard-pressed to describe
that book as flawed in any way but i
think also because we knew of the pr
stanford prison experiments and also
we're looking for an easy explanation
for what happened in nazi germany that
it's comforting for people to believe
that a totalitarian state is basically
made up of people yearning to be free
who are oppressed
um but basically honest by a small
minority of people willing to use
coercion and terror and there is a small
coercion and terror however in a true
totalitarian state and this is social
instance genius
the the the totalitarian element of that
is actually the willingness of every
single person virtually without
exception in the entire society
to lie about everything all the time to
absolutely everyone themselves their
wife or husband their children their
parents their siblings the people they
work with and so it is and this is
something that reading solzhenitsyn
really convinced me of and of course
part of the reason i was attracted to
your book it is the idea that
p that root to totalitarianism
at the individual level is the
willingness
to knowingly falsify
your speech and perception and action to
knowingly do it too not just to do it by
accident but to know it's wrong and
still do it that's the pathway to hell
yeah you know jordan uh cheswald miwosch
who was a former communist who defected
from poland in the 1950s wrote an
excellent book in the early 50s called
the captive mind and in it he tried to
describe to the west why people fell for
communism and he said that a lot of
people in the west have this false idea
that people did it solely because they
were coerced he said in fact there is
among everybody it's part of our human
nature this deep internal longing for
harmony and happiness a lot of these
people in eastern europe yeah they were
they were invaded by the soviets who
occupied them after the war but a lot of
them were exhausted by the war and they
thought communism would give them a
sense of wholeness it would give them a
sense of meaning and purpose to their
lives and so they submitted to it also
ann applebaum who's a historian of the
iron curtain said that most people in
this part of the world because i'm
coming to you now from budapest most
people in this part of the world didn't
make a deal a conscious deal with the
devil to us to embrace communism they
were just tired and worn down by
constant propaganda and just wanted to
have a normal life and if that meant
having to submit to the lies well they
were willing to do so
well
so
there's another element of that that's
interesting as well so we could go two
directions on that the first is that
under many conditions the human
proclivity to go along with the dictates
of the group is actually an admirable
proclivity and so you know parents of
teenagers often say to their teenagers
well if your friends jumped off a bridge
would you jump too
and the answer to that is actually
generally yes
and to make it even more complicated is
that that's exactly what teenagers
should be doing because they should be
substituting
integration in the peer group for
dependence on the parents and so
whether or not they fit in is of
cardinal importance to a teenager who's
developing properly and so people should
go along with the crowd in some sense
because that's what it means to be
civilized into a broad community the
problem with that is that sometimes the
crowd is a mob and sometimes society has
gone off the rails and so
then what do you do and the answer to
some degree is well
you develop past being a teenager into
an autonomous individual who's an
autonomous contributor to the group and
then hopefully you have enough
what would you say moral integrity to
stand for what you see and think when
you're called upon to do that but that's
we don't know the preconditions that
allow people to do that and then on the
communist front i would say so you
talked about people being worn out
there is also that and this is one of
the things that distinguished communism
from nazism let's say and made it even
maybe more pernicious
the nazis basically said
well
the world that's for the aryans and the
rest of you can go to hell and we'll be
happy to do to aid in the
flames let's say
and
there's not a universalism associated
with that there's a definite exclusion
and it's pretty bloody obvious
on the communist front though and this
is maybe what made it such a powerful
substitute in some sense for for
christianity
there was the notion that what we were
working for was the universal
brotherhood of man and this intense
inclusiveness where everyone could live
together peacefully and so people were
also led down the garden path by that
presumption and found out that
lying in the service of future utopia
turns out to be a pathway to hell just
like lying in the service of an
exclusionary fascist state
right i you know i i was sitting in a a
russian family's apartment in moscow
when i was in russia reporting the book
and i'd spent the last three days prior
three days out visiting uh the monument
for
the the the dead from political violence
and hearing just incredible stories of
atrocities and suffering and i was
sitting there my last night in moscow
having dinner with the family and i said
at the beginning i just don't understand
how anybody could have believed what the
bolsheviks were preaching
the father
at the head of the table these were all
orthodox christians who were
anti-communist but he said you don't
want to you don't know how people did
this let me tell you and then he goes on
this long discourse about 300 years of
russian history about incredible
exploitation and cruelty by the czars by
the ruling class even by the church
and he said by the time you got to the
end of the 19th century when people
began to lose faith in the established
order people read it were ready to
believe anything that gave them a sense
of relief then the father ended by
saying look i'm not saying the
bolsheviks were right they were evil but
you can see where they came from and i i
think
put it going forward to our own time
when you live in a situation as we do
today in the west where people are
radically atomized there's this deep uh
disrespect and
casting over of hierarchies and
institutions when you have people who
want to transgress for the sake of
transgression and so on and so forth all
of these are points that hannah aaron
said were precursors to totalitarianism
well it's no wonder that people
otherwise intelligent people are willing
to accept insane ideological ideas
because they think somehow they're
convinced that this is going to bring
about a better world
well it's also the case i think that
we we all bear the burden of
in some sense original sin in
relationship to the atrocities of the
past and the left has been very good at
weaponizing this and so when we're
accused
in our western privilege of
un
justly benefiting from the conditions of
our birth
there's some truth in that and there's
some truth in the claim that those
unjust conditions were purchased
to
some not small degree
at the cost of the blood of others
and so then that produces a moral
conundrum in people which is well
i know that i've been thrown into this
world
with
arbitrary benefits now arbitrary burdens
as well and that's important to remember
arbitrary benefits i'm i'm healthy i'm
reasonably wealthy i'm of a race that's
had some advantages let's say
i'm born in the united states etc and it
could have been otherwise and look at
all these poor people who are struggling
with nothing and
how much of that was purchased at the
price of slavery and atrocity and
those are all extremely good questions
and i've been trying to think through
that more recently to help people defend
themselves against accusations put
forward about such things by the radical
resentful who will manipulate it the way
that you atone for the unequal
distribution of talents is to accept
that you have some responsibility
to make the best possible use of the
advantages that have been granted to you
and so i think the only way that people
can defend themselves against the
accusations of
unfair and atrocious atrocious privilege
thrown at them by the utopia utopian
resentful types is by
striving to live a life that's as moral
as
paying for their privilege demands and
there's an ethical element to that
that's deep right deep enough to really
be regarded in some sense as religious
right right to whom much is given much
is expected exactly that yes and uh but
you know i as i was listening to you
talk i was thinking about my late father
who was born in deep rural poverty in
south louisiana in the great depression
and this was a man who didn't have
indoor plumbing in his house until he
installed it as a senior in high school
in the early 1950s
but he was able to benefit from the gi
bill after the war and he was the first
in his family to go to college
and he built a middle class existence
and sent his kids to college and so on
and so forth well when i was reading
russian history about the kulaks the the
prosperous peasants and how stalin and
lenin
singled them out for extermination i
think a people like my dad those who
knew what you could do through hard work
and self-discipline and using your
talents in the right way
that's why stalin had to get rid of the
kulaks because they stood as
as living
disproves of the bolshevik ideology
which is the only way anybody gets ahead
is by cheating
yeah well the story of the kulak should
send a chill down the heart chill into
the heart of anybody
who has any dignity
discipline and sense
as i really threw myself in imagination
into the kulak world thinking about the
little town that i grew up in
um my parents were very much of the same
sort of people that you describe
your father as a
so imagine that in a little town
there's a
emerging from poverty there's a
smattering of people who are clambering
their way towards a
reasonably prosperous upper
working-class or middle-class existence
right and they're doing that because
they work
bloody hard they're disciplined and
dedicated and maybe they get enough
capital
to hire someone to help them house clean
and maybe to hire a couple of hired
hands on the would have been the farm at
that time
and let's say they're the first people
in town to do that
and everyone else who's striving away
mightily to attain the same end admires
their efforts but there's a small
coterie of machiavellian psychopaths on
the fringe who are jealous as hell of
them and who
are primed and ready to regard their
attainments as theft
and then a swarm of intellectual
bolshevists ride into town and say hey
you know anybody who has more than you
is an exploiter and a thief and the
moral thing to do is to
take what they have
and if not kill them and rape them then
at least ship them somewhere where they
can't do any more harm and then you ask
well
to whom does that message appeal and he
might say well to egalitarian utopians
but how about no how about to
the machiavellian fringe psychopaths
who've been waiting for an excuse to rob
and pillage and now have been provided
with it by the convenient doctrines of
idiot intellectuals and then imagine
yourself in a town like that where those
insane
vicious
cruel
resentful bullies now have the weapons
the upper hand and the moral authority
of the government
and that was decoupagization yep yep
that's true and uh it's it's just
breathtaking to see something similar
happening today again thank god we don't
have a siberia that's why i call this
soft totalitarianism as opposed to the
hard version of the soviet union but we
still have a system now put in place not
only by the government maybe not even
mostly by the government but by every
major institution in western life the
media the universities the military big
business vote capitalism and so on and
so forth which adopt this same foolish
egalitarianism
and they will marginalize those who
stand against it those who stand against
it and can prove that they're good
because by the quality of their work you
know i i think that there's some it's a
relevant passage that martin lazis he
was the head of the checker the
precursor to the kgb uh in ukraine back
in the early years of the revolution
there's a passage from one of his
writings that applies to us today lazis
said told the agents to go down into
ukraine and judge people not on the
basis of whether or not they had
actually spoken out against the soviet
order but rather look at their class
file look at where they worked who their
people were and then punish them on that
that he said is the basis of the red
terror and this is what you get when you
have a system and an ideology that
privileges people or judges people on
the basis of group identity not
individual the quality of individual
character or individual work
this is something that is pushed in our
own culture today
not from the bottom up but it's coming
from the real revolutionary class which
are the intellectuals who have marched
through the institutions
it is the intellectuals but you pointed
to something too which is really to me
almost staggeringly incomprehensible and
that's the emergence of woke capitalism
and so i look at these ceos like the ceo
of disney
and i think
are you actually so daft
that you don't notice that you're
empowering a fifth column within your
own organization do you actually not
understand that equity means in the
final analysis that you get to get shot
first do you do you not see that the
unequal distribution that characterizes
the capitalist enterprise and at least
in principle based on more going to
those who work harder although it's an
imperfect system is exactly the opposite
of what the equity agitators are
striving for and why is it that you're
enabling that within your hr departments
within your own corporation and so i
mean we can point our fingers at the
idiot professors and we should but then
what the hell's up with the evil
capitalist overlords like are they so
clueless that they can't even what do
they want they want to not take
responsibility for the fruits of their
own success that they want to play both
ends against the middle or is it just
blindness like i don't understand this
no it's guilt i remember when i worked
in news rooms yeah most of my career uh
we the people who are pushing equity
so-called equity and diversity and
hiring which often meant hiring people
who weren't good enough to do the jobs
that they were being given this was all
being pushed by white upper management
who were trying in my view to atone for
their own anxiety or to get ready to
discharge their own anxiety about their
privilege and the people who are paying
the price for it were those people who
were truly capable farther down the
chain there because you would never you
would never see these white upper
managers resign to make plays for a
person of color or you know a gay person
or a minority person no they were making
other people
deal with their own the upper
management's anxieties and sense that
they were frauds and i think it was also
a form of indulgences in the middle in
the middle age uh the medieval catholic
sense of indulgences if they would use
their power to put um you know the
oppressed in places in positions within
the company then they felt that they had
somehow gained uh holiness or gained
yeah well do you think we should be
cynical or sympathetic about that or
both so imagine
working on the argument that we were
developing earlier is that
as you pointed out if you've been given
much much will be asked
from you and let's say that if you're
a
middle class upper middle class manager
of a decent corporation in the united
states a lot has been given to you
and so what that means actually is a lot
is being demanded of you even by your
own conscience right because you look
around and you see your wealth and you
see your opportunity and you contrast
that say when you walk down the street
and see a homeless person you contrast
that with the privation that still
exists around you and if you're a
vaguely decent person that sets up an
unease and a disquiet in your conscience
and then you might say well in order to
expiate that unease you have to live as
morally as you are wealthy
and failing that then you're going to do
you're going to take maybe the renee
gerard route and look for scapegoats
you're going to look for someone else to
sacrifice so that you act morally
instead of bearing that burden on
yourself
so but but you know it's a tricky thing
right because on the one hand you can
you can admire the fact that the the
pangs of conscience are requiring action
on the ethical front
but then you have to be cynical about
the fact that while you're trying to
take an easy route out by making someone
else pay instead of actually doing the
work that would free you from the pangs
of your own conscience in the face of
your privilege
yeah and i think i'm glad you brought up
renee gerard because i i quote him in
the book is saying that the proper and
morally
justifiable concern for victims was
turning rather into a permanent
inquisition and a system of totalitarian
command gerard saw this in 20 years ago
and now we're living with it so this was
as you were saying earlier why communism
was more uh easier to to accept than
nazism because communism really did take
the proper concern for victims but they
created hell on earth by by taking it
too far and i think jordan that one of
the
the the key missing points here is
christianity
christianity is a religion that concerns
it stands up for the poor and the
victimized it takes a side of the
victimize but christianity also has
buried deep within it the point that
solzhenitsyn made like this that the
line between good and evil does not pass
between social classes or identity
groups it passes right down the middle
of every human heart
any oppressed person can easily become
the oppressor tomorrow because human uh
failure human frailty original sin is
common to human nature and we saw this
in the communist world where those who
really did suffer a lot under
the regimes they overthrew became even
worse oppressors themselves
well so
here's the moral hazard that goes along
with that guilt that you described so
imagine that you're now because you have
privilege you're concerned about those
who have been victimized and who have
less
and so then you could take the steps
necessary to be properly philanthropic
productive and generous with your time
and your resources or you could take an
easy route and this is the scapegoat
route you could identify
the oppressors who have oppressed the
victims and who are actually responsible
for their existence and those oppressors
are not you they're someone else and
then your morality consists in ferreting
out the oppressors and damning them and
and mobbing them and and chasing them
away which is essentially what happened
let's say with the kulaks in the in the
soviet union and so
the the cost of not it's the problem of
placing satan as far as i'm concerned is
that you have to have a place where you
where you
where you localize evil
and
it's convenient to localize it in others
and it's ethically justifiable to
identify oppressors who produce victims
and convenient if they're not you but
the proper locale for
satan and i think this is part of the
whole judeo-christian enterprise to
specify this properly is that that is in
fact inside your own heart and that what
you should do to constrain evil and
that's really what we're talking about
in this podcast period is to take on the
moral burden that produces atrocity in
the world onto yourself and
solzhenitsyn's advice was
while you start by stop by not lying
that's the first thing you do let me
read out some of his rules for
responsible conduct it's like a bill of
responsibilities we can think of it that
way instead of bill of rights
i will not say right affirm
or distribute
anything that distorts the truth
i will not go to a demonstration or
participate in a collective action
unless i truly believe in the cause
i will not take part in a meeting
in which the discussion is forced and no
one can speak the truth i will not vote
for a candidate or proposal i consider
to be dubious or unworthy
i will walk out of an event as soon as i
hear the speaker utter a lie
ideological drivel or shameless
propaganda well that would produce a lot
of abandonment to a lot of meetings
right now it would and it will not
support just journalism that distorts or
hides the underlying facts
and so
solzhenitsyn this is one of the things i
so greatly admired about his work and
also about about your book
his
his diagnosis was that it was the
willingness to knowingly deceive
yourself and other people that
generated and supported the totalitarian
catastrophe and that your primarily all
primary obligation was to cease
participating in that
and so and that does place the tempter
the deceiver and so the prince of all
lies let's say lucifer himself in your
own heart and puts on you the moral
weight of
engaging in that battle
in the
in the psychological or spiritual space
and and that also see this is one of the
reasons i dislike modern universities so
much is because what they do instead of
helping students develop their moral
character or even talking about such a
thing as a moral character
is that they teach the students to
identify the perpetrators
and then to
protest against them and then that can
easily so easily transform itself into
this scapegoating and mob
culture that we have now all operating
under the flag of a moral banner
right because they don't see the
capacity for evil within their own
hearts right and reason is
it's sadly it seems to be impotent
against this sort of thing i i think
jordan that one of the most important
events cultural events of our time
happened on yale university's campus in
october 2015. you'll remember this when
uh the the students got so angry
undergraduates at
nicholas christakis and his wife erica
simply for saying they thought that the
students should be able to make up their
own minds about the kind of halloween
costumes to wear you'll remember this
became a huge blow up on campus and on
youtube people filmed this confrontation
on on the quad there at princeton
between nicholas christopher's this
liberal distinguished professor with
white hair baby boomer and these kids
there was nicholas christopher's trying
to use reason to to engage these young
people in dialogue they didn't want
anything to do with it they were
screaming and crying and cursing and
demanding that he apologized for for his
lack of care and it went nowhere and as
you recall yale university the
administration sided with the students
that was a collapse of authority right
there but it also signaled the collapse
of rationality and this was repeated
many more times in other universities
over the subsequent years but when it
happens to the elites like that in the
the universities where the uh elites are
formed and elite networks are formed
that is when the revolution really takes
off
yeah well it was appalling on the part
of yale to side with the students and
not with the professor and that was a
that was a sign of a catastrophic
collapse and also of the inability of
those who hold the
reigns of tradition let's say to defend
themselves against
the
even the most unsophisticated
accusations of group guilt because
people are guilty especially if they're
conscientious you know what the other
thing that bothers me about the
universities a lot
there's many things but
one of the things that jean piaget
noted the developmental psychologist you
know he was interested in bridging the
gap between religion and science say
that was the fundamental motivation for
his entire life's work by the way very
few people know that um because that's
one of the odd things about geniuses you
know is that we tend not to take their
true motivations that seriously because
it's too disturbing but piaget pointed
out that the last stage of cognitive
moral development in adolescence in late
adolescence was something that he
described as the emergence of the
messianic impulse
and so imagine that
when you're uh
mid
age teenager 15 16 something like that
your primary concern is get away from
your family of origin start to establish
independence but do that by
becoming a stalwart member of your in
group right
so you you move your allegiance from the
family to the broader community and you
do that with your friends but then
there's a step past that where you're
trying to sort out what your
ethical obligation is to the to yourself
and the broader community at large which
is something like the perp specifying
the grand purpose of your life and that
produces especially among ambitious and
perhaps better young people is the
desire to do something important with
their lives
and then they go to university and
instead of being
chastised i would say in some real sense
which is to be taught look
you've got lots of potential but you
don't really know anything you've got
15 years of apprenticeship in front of
you before you're the kind of tool that
won't cause trouble when it's applied
and so just
sit back and
subject yourself to the long
apprenticeship that's going to
discipline you
get your life together mature learn how
to work learn how to be productive and
then go out and and do what you can to
improve the world for the better they're
taught instead that
the mere existence of their youthful
outrage which is compromised in its
integrity by their resentful sense that
they're at the bottom of the hierarchy
which in some sense is true that's all
uh
harnessed to the ideological demands of
the resentful faculty who i think are
mostly irritated because they're not
making as much money as bankers you know
it's a really pathological
it's a really pathological system of
interplay
and so the faculty members can can
absolve themselves of moral blame by
pointing at the evil of capitalists who
are despoiling the world that's
convenient for them because of course
those evil capitalists have more money
than they do and they should be more
rewarded given their genius and they can
stick the students on them that's the
scapegoating that gerard uh that gerard
described and then it
wraps up the whole problem in a neat
little bow except that it's the students
who like it's a catastrophe for those
students at yale to have got a law to
have got away with being a demented
neurotic mob
and undermining the authority of a
distinguished professor it's like what
the hell were they paying for at yale if
it wasn't the opportunity to subjugate
themselves in an apprenticeship sense to
distinguish professors is that all just
a lie well that's what yale said its
status you know jordan a few years ago a
friend of mine from europe a journalist
was at harvard on a neiman fellowship
you know very prestigious journalism
fellowship where they bring about 25
journalists from around the world and 25
from the united states to harvard to
spend a year taking
graduate classes well i happen to be in
boston when this guy's fellowship is
ending and i took him out to lunch to
ask him what have you learned the
biggest lessons you've learned at the
most prestigious institution of higher
learning in the united states he thought
about it for a second and said how
fragile the american elites are i said
that's interesting can you help help me
understand that he said that when they
started classes at the in the fall
semester
professors would say things to the
students like these are graduate
students right like uh class we're not
going to talk about this issue or that
issue today because a couple of you came
to me ahead of class and said it would
be too triggering so it we're just not
going to talk about it my friend said
all of us europeans looked at each other
like wait is this guy serious but he was
serious and this happened in class after
class after class
the europeans said by the end of the
semester he
realized how fragile the next generation
of leaders of america would be because
they are so weak that they can't deal
with the anxiety caused by issues and
questions and ideas raised that they
would be required to grapple with on the
other hand he said every single one of
them believed that they had a natural
right to move into positions of
leadership the guy ended by telling me
look i i get to go back to europe i
don't have to live with this but the
safety and security of my country
depends on a strong america we're not
going to have a strong america because
your ruling class is so corrupt and so
weak and they will use whatever power
they are given to suppress anything that
causes them anxiety
yeah well and they're also possessed of
the idiot progressive postmodern notion
that all reality is just ideas anyways
and so you can avoid difficult
discussions and then you avoid the
difficulty because after all the real
world where the actual difficulties are
doesn't even exist and when you're in a
university bubble and you're a protected
faculty member you can actually get away
with that idea for quite a long time
because in some sense
there are so many walls surrounding you
from the real world that
you can dance blindly
you know on the way to your own grave
without even noticing that you're doing
something pathological yeah but look
jordan it's happened it's gone beyond
the universities now as we know uh just
before we came on to record this i sent
you a tweet from the toronto police
department saying uh this woman has gone
missing and it's a 27 year old man
with a beard and i mean he's clearly a
man he calls himself isabelle and now
you're in trouble now how you're in
trouble
well you know it's what is what is a
woman as i've heard asked by the daily
wire folks but you know what's crazy
about this is it made me think of
orwell's line in in
1984 he said the party's final and most
essential command was that you deny the
evidence of your eyes and your ears this
is happening on a widespread basis
that's the true test of loyalty yep yep
loyalty to the system yeah and then
reliability and and yeah reliability and
hypothetically moral integrity all of
that if you'll sacrifice your own eyes
to if you'll sacrifice your own eyes to
the cause then how could there be any
evidence that you're anything but
morally superior right well a man named
patrick benda and the czech republic his
father and mother were legendary
dissidents dad went to prison under
communism for his dissident activities
he told me that you have to remember
that even before communism came into
power
20 years at least before all the
intelligentsia had gone over to
socialism or communism and if you wanted
to have any part in the intelligentsia
you had to make that conversion too well
clearly the same thing has been
happening in our societies with regard
to gender ideology to critical race
theory and all these other elements of
woke ideology if you want to get into
the intelligentsia you have to believe
that but not only the intelligentsia if
you want to get into law school into
medicine into the u.s military for god's
sake uh and into big business you have
to affirm these lies so one of the
things one of the big lessons of live
not by lies came from watsonville the
the first president of a free
czechoslovakia and a playwright who led
the opposition
in communist czechoslovakia he wrote
this famous parable called the the myth
of the green grocer he said imagine
there's a little green grocer in your
communist country and like every other
business owner in town he puts up the
sign in his window that says workers of
the world unite nobody believes it but
they put that commented slogan there
because they don't want trouble but what
happens one day when the green grocer
decides to take that sign down from his
window well the secret police come they
arrest him that he loses his business
when he gets out of jail he's got to
work as a street sweeper he's humiliated
his family loses privileges and on and
on he really pays a price for his
dissent but what has he gained by that
hubble says he has shown the world that
it is possible to live in truth to live
in integrity if you are willing to
suffer for it and if enough people do
that said hovel then the everyone will
start to question all the lies the
system is built on that it has to start
with people who are willing to suffer
for their kids okay so so let's
interject or just for a second
one of the things i used to tell my
clients when they were facing a
conundrum was
you're
you're trapped in an illusion because
you want to keep your job although you
hate it because you're afraid of the
alternative
but you're discounting the risk of
maintaining your current course you're
used to that and the risk has been
discounted
and you're suffering under the delusion
that there's a pathway forward that does
not involve suffering
and that's simply not true
what you have is the option of picking
your suffering and so the problem with
the green grocer who puts the slogan up
in his window is he thinks that he's
avoiding suffering but he's not he's
delaying it and amplifying it for his
future self
once you understand that because people
have commented they tell me well you're
so correct courageous and i think well
no you you don't understand
i'm just afraid of the right thing
i know that there's catastrophe to the
right and catastrophe to the left and
catastrophe straight ahead let's say
but i also know that
conflict delayed is conflict multiplied
and if i have to pick suffering right
now because i'm going to say what i
bloody well think and suffering later
way more intensely with way more other
people because i refuse to say what i
think i'm going to pick the former and
i'm not going to delude myself that
there's some safe path that involves
lying because there isn't
that's and that that's another thing
well another reason i liked your book is
and this is soldier instance
um
what would you call it his key insight
in some sense is that
you think that lying protects you
that's wrong and you think well how
could it possibly protect you what
you're trying to do is to adapt to the
world
and if you lie so that you're no longer
adapted to the world then you're going
to run into sharp objects and in and
fall into holes non-stop and the blinder
you are the sharper the objects and the
deeper the holes and when you really
understand that like once i understood
schnitzel's connection between lying in
the totalitarian state
i mean i had come at that for other
reasons as well but he was a big
contributor to that realization i
thought well there's no way i'm going to
say things that are false because that's
clearly
that's the road to hell
not metaphysically not
philosophically
actually really for sure this will
happen and as a clinician this is one of
the things that also terrified me
i never saw anyone ever get away with
anything
the chickens always came home to roost
people paid for every sin
sometimes it took them years to draw the
causal connections
but a lot of what therapy was was
well let's see if we can figure out
something went wrong
let's see if we can figure out when
let's see if we can figure out why
let's see if we can figure out how to
undo it you remember in solzhenitsyn in
the second part of the gulag
second volume of the gulag archipelago i
think
he said that when he was in prison
and decided that part of the reason he
was there was because he was a sinner
because he made mistakes
he decided because he had so much time
on his hands that he would go through
his entire life with a fine tooth comb
try to recollect every single time he
violated his conscience
and then see if he could figure out how
to atone for that in the present
and that's basically the
psychotherapeutic process it's like
where did you go wrong how did you lie
how can you set yourself back on the
appropriate path
and i think that's the fear of god
that's the beginning of wisdom in some
sense it's like
what's the old idea there's a book where
everything you've ever done is written
down
yeah that book that's reality itself
and you do not have the power to
twist or distort reality without it
snapping back at you in ways that you
can hardly possibly imagine
and remember what um solzhenitsyn said
bless you prison
i mean great imagine he was he suffered
horribly in prison but he said bless you
prison because it brought him to that
salvation it brought him out of himself
yeah well then he was also honest enough
by the way when he did say that to say
i do say that knowing that so many
innocent and good people
died in those prisons and were tortured
beyond recovery
and did not have the benefit of that
eventual redemption right because that's
suffering that suffering that's a real
that's real trouble it's not and there's
no
necessary
proof that if you undertake to suffer
for the truth that
you won't pay the final price
the problem is
you're going to pay a price for the
alternative too and so will everybody
else and you know that's another
metaphysical issue in some sense you
know what's worth death or what's worse
death or hell
and i would say if you think it's death
all that means is you haven't been to
hell yet
hmm that's powerful
you know i and i think that one aspect
of this new totalitarianism we're
dealing with is the fear not only no
fear of hell but fear but fear of
of uh being inconvenienced fear of
anxiety here in budapest
when i was in this city
researching the book my translator was
with me on the tram and she was a young
woman a young catholic woman uh married
with one little boy at home and another
on the way and uh as we grew to the city
on the tram to do an interview she said
you know rod i really struggle with my
catholic friends here um she herself is
catholic i i when i try to tell them
that my husband and i have been fighting
lately or my little boy is really
causing me a lot of sleepless nights
because he's not sleeping well they say
oh you've got to get a divorce you've
got to uh put your child in daycare go
back to work you've got to be happy she
said i tell them wait a minute you don't
understand i am happy uh but you know a
happy life also entails some struggle
she said they don't understand it at all
i looked at her and said anna it sounds
like you're fighting for your right to
be unhappy she said that's exactly it
where did you get that and i
brought my phone out and went to chapter
17 of huxley's brave new world where
john the savage who confronts mustafa
man the world controller of this perfect
state where everybody all their needs
are taken care of they're entertained at
all times they get lots of drugs lots of
feel-good drugs lots of porn etc etc he
brings in the dissident john the savage
to say
why wouldn't you join this we give you
christianity without tears
and in the end uh
the john doesn't want this he wants real
life he wants reality even with it
so let's let let's think that through
for a minute that's that's actually
pretty straightforward in some sense so
one of the things solzhenitsyn
said about hedonism he said the doctrine
that life is for happiness is
invalidated by this the first sound of
the jack boots kicking into your door
and so then the question is well what do
you do in the face of suffering when
your philosophy is hedonic is he is
hedonistic
and the answer is collapse
and that means that
happiness as an aim is
is shallow and weak
it cannot withstand suffering obviously
because when you're suffering you're not
happy and if the purpose of life is to
be happy then suffering
when you're suffering your life has no
meaning and then if you're suffering and
there's no meaning in the suffering then
you're really suffering that's really
hell
but then you think and this is something
that's really heartened me i talk to my
audiences especially to the young men
say look
first of all don't aim at being happy
because
that's
just not gonna work especially when the
storms come and
barbarians are beating at the gate you
can just forget about that and there's
gonna be times in your life where you're
suffering so much you can't believe it
and so you're going to need something a
hell of a lot more robust than happiness
to get you through that
and then you might say well what's more
robust than happiness
or maybe even what's more robust than
pain
and then you could say well how about
adventure
how about adventure how about we go out
and sail the uncharted seas you know how
about we go and jesus i talked to a guy
the other day he's a driver for me down
in uh
down in nashville where i am ex-military
guy special forces guy
tough as a bloody boot now works as a
cowboy out in montana you know a real
character
perfect bloody american archetype he
knew he wanted to be in the special
forces when he was five
so i talked to him for like half an hour
trying to figure out what motivated him
you know and he told me probably 10
stories about his life all very
colorful
and deep anecdotes battle and
and rescue and physical privation and
discipline and
every 10 minutes he said i was looking
for a new challenge
and then i was looking for a new
challenge and then i'd already done that
so i was looking for a new challenge and
for him
life was nothing but a sequence of
impossible mountains to climb
and that's exactly what he wanted and
that's what i think we all want you know
in in the story of abraham when abraham
is perfectly happy in his father's tent
eating peeled grapes and you know having
his diapers changed even though he's 80
years old and god calls him out to it to
adventure
and it's very
catastrophic right because abraham
encounters
tyranny and starvation and war and
conspiracy to steal his wife and his own
proclivity to lie cowardly and this is
all like in the that's his first
sequence of adventures
and you think well what the hell's going
on here it's certainly not the case that
god called him out to be happy and i
think the right moral to draw from that
story is that god so to speak has called
us out for something far greater than
mere happiness
far so much greater than happiness that
happiness pales in comparison he's
called us out for the adventure of our
life that's of sufficient moral
integrity to justify the suffering
and that's something and if you tell
people that if if you let them know that
you know well that makes them stand up
and cheer right because deep in their
heart they know that's true
especially demoralized young men they're
not from churches today from church
leaders god
quite the contrary they're they're
they're hearing
that spirit of adventure calls you to be
a patriarchal despoiler of the planet
and that demoralizes young men and
that's of course exactly the point
because demoralized young men aren't
oppressors although yes they are
and they're not the spoilers of the
planet although yes they are
and so
so happiness it's like you know that's
just that's just
happiness is a side effect of moral
venture you know and if it comes along
you should be bloody thrilled but as a
name it's for it's for narcissistic
three-year-olds as a name you know join
the the last chapter of the book is a
pretty hopeful chapter and interesting
about the the point you've just made uh
i met when i was in bratislava in
slovakia
a young photographer named teemo krishna
and timo was a toddler when communism
ended so he was brought up with much
more freedom and material
many more material benefits than his
parents and his grandparents uh but he
said that the higher he rose in his
profession and the more money he made
the more uh anxious he was and the less
happy he was well he set out at one
point to go do a photography project by
interviewing the elderly people in his
country christians who had been sent to
the gulag in slovakia for their faith
and a lot of them still lived in real
poverty today and they had suffered
terribly for their faith but he said as
he went to take their picture and hear
their stories he saw people who were
deeply at peace and deeply happy one man
even told him that solitary confinement
was one of the happiest times of his
life in retrospect because there he
communed with god and he knew he had
union with god timo told me in the end
this really changed him because he
realized that he himself and was the
tyrant in his life because he had been
seeking happiness and riches and all
that whereas he should have been seeking
god
like these old people who had suffered
had i think this is the kind of
christianity that young people can
respect but nobody respects this
moralistic therapeutic deism or the
social gospel kind of woke christianity
it's going into the dust benefit no it's
just an it's just another form of of
woke idiot utopianism the kind that
finds devils everywhere except in the
soul and that's concerned with group
redemption and not with the travails of
individual
progress towards the divine let's say
and that is what the churches can offer
let's talk about that a minute so you
talk in the book too as
ideology as substitute for religion and
i had smart students at
harvard in particular but also at the
university of toronto when i was
lecturing on my book maps of meaning
i was trying to put forward an antidote
to ideology
and the students would say well why is
your conceptual system not just another
ideology and that's a very that's a very
complicated question and it's a
post-modern question in some sense right
because all systems of knowledge are
nothing but structures for the
imposition of power and there's no way
out of that and so there's no such thing
as an anti-ideology wisdom there's just
another ideology now i don't believe
that's true
but
you've talked about ideology as a
substitute for religion and so why are
you convinced that the religious claims
that you abide by and put forth are not
merely another form of ideology and
another another what would you say mask
for the manifestation of power right
right because i believe that they are
rooted in transcendent truth and truths
that have withstood the test of time i'm
an orthodox christian eastern orthodox
christian uh the roots of my confession
go back to the very beginnings of
christianity and it is a form of the
faith that i believe is true to human
nature and and true to the way the world
is constructed you know i was recently
uh interviewing uh ian mcgill chris so i
know you've interviewed him or he's
interviewed you in england he's a
psychiatrist who is not a religious
believer as far as i know but he talks
about the the mind and the brain
hemispheres and the making of the
western world and he has talked about he
told me that if he were to convert to
christianity he would become orthodox
because he believes that orthodox
christianity gives the best account for
reality
for the way humans move
in the world and
and take in the world
i think also that and why did he why did
he say that specifically of orthodoxy
was it its emphasis on ritual it was the
emphasis on um the idea that you have to
have a balance between the left and the
right the right hemisphere is the noetic
where noetic information comes in and
and in uh ian's construct western
religion has become too left-brained
it's become too logical to caught up in
creating a that's the idea well sam
harris has come to the same conclusion
in some sense despite himself because
harris is the ultimate rationalist and i
would say for for very positive reasons
in some regard because harris is deeply
concerned with atrocity but
that was so unbalanced that he turned to
a meditative buddhism that has an
completely amorphous deity in some sense
at its base
amorphous enough so that sam's corrosive
rationality cannot take issue with it
and he finds solace and respite in the
meditative practice and now he spends
most of his time developing his
meditation app and teaching meditation
courses that's a good example of the
sort of thing that ian is pointing to
yeah
i think too that ideology tends to be
very very brittle and tends to be a
left-brained construct that tries to
impose uh a purely human rationalistic
framework onto messy reality and you
know that's a tower of babel eh right
that's the warning of the tower of babel
ideology can't deal with contradiction
with the ultimate mystery and paradox of
of human life
and uh and i think stephen pinker had a
quote that was in the new york times
today as we're talking
where he was talking about wokeness and
why wokeness is ultimately going to fail
he said it is a
an algorithm for constant for permanent
inquisition because none of these
artificial constructs can deal with
messy humanity and with human freedom i
think that christianity
can deal with human freedom it has
ultimate right and ultimate wrong but it
also recognizes that humans are frail
and it calls for mercy
causes for us to be humble and to
recognize that every one of us is a
sinner every one of us is capable of
being the grand inquisitor if given the
right opportunities
so
one of the things that
struck me
mostly from reading jung in his school
and their inquiry into the archetype of
the hero was that there was something in
the hero narratives that was counter
ideological
in the deepest sense and so an ideology
is a luciferian enterprise and it
attempts to bring the entire purview of
reality under an axiomatic system under
the dog or the dogmatic dictates of an
axiomatic system and woe to you if you
challenge the axioms let's say that
makes you a heretic and worthy of being
mobbed um
and so you might ask well
what what truth might we find
that can be regarded as transcendentally
axiomatic that's also also not
luciferian and i think that
christianity you see this in the
prophetic tradition in judaism as well
but christianity insists that there are
two
ele there insists on the existence of at
least two elements that have that nature
and one is that
the highest
should most properly serve the lowest
and so that the the hallmark of true
sovereignty is the willingness of the
elite let's say the talented
the productive the blessed the gifted
to
to justify the unequal division of
talent by serving to ameliorate the
catastrophic suffering of the
dispossessed
now nietzsche warned about that right he
thought that
christianity would devolve in some sense
into the woke nightmare that it has
devolved into but i think he failed to
give the devil his entire due the notion
that the highest
is the highest because it voluntarily
serves the lowest that's a deadly idea
and i don't think it's an ideological
idea at all i think it's an idea that
removes the paradox of human existence
and so and that so there's that but then
there's another insistence in both
judaism and christianity and i'm not
saying it's limited to those doctrines
by the way that
the way to deal with suffering
is not to avoid it or to circumvent it
with a shallow hedonism but to face it
intensely
head on and voluntarily in its full
manifestation and so one of the things
i've realized about the passion story
which we which jung regarded as an
archetypal tragedy and in some sense a
limit case right a story so tragic that
you cannot write a more tragic story
right is that it drags the
observer and so that's all of us in the
in christendom
through the entire catastrophe of human
existence
right so it confronts you
with the mob the mob that's after you
that you are also part of it confronts
you with moral relativism in the face in
the shape of pontius pilate it confronts
you with the oppression of the
totalitarian state of foreigners let's
say in the case in the in the guys of
rome it confronts you with the betrayal
of your best friend
it confronts you with the willingness of
the crowd to
punish the virtuous and free the
criminal and that's the story of
barabbas and christ and pajo told me of
the other day jonathan pagio that an
alternative name for barabbas was jesus
and that what the crowd did was pick the
political revolutionary
over the spiritual
leader
and that's perfect and then it confronts
you with the reality that we all face
our own mortality and too early and the
fact that sometimes the innocent and
virtuous are punished and so
it and then of course there's the
horrible tragic torturous death all of
that
and that's all signified by the image of
the crucifix and what what what we're
doing to ourselves even though we don't
know it i'm speaking mostly
psychologically although somewhat
theologically is that
we're exposing ourselves to the ultimate
catastrophe of human existence while
simultaneously manifesting the faith
the faith that if we face that
unflinchingly
that will resurrect us instead of
killing us
that's quite powerful it's something man
it's something it's something i've been
puzzling out for well a long time but
particularly for the last six months
i'm gonna write about that in my new
book but and when i talk to my audiences
about that you know and i would
especially say this has an impact again
on demoralized young men and say look
we don't know the limits to the
expansion of your personality if you're
willing to face things without deception
that's that that's a variant of that
radical honesty we're already talking
about don't live by lies well life is
rife with injustice atrocity and
suffering
and so what do you do with that do you
avoid it
there's good physiological evidence by
the way that
if you take two groups of people
and you subject one group to a stressor
involuntarily
and you get the other group to take on
the stressor voluntarily that the
pattern of psychophysiological response
is entirely different
it's entirely different emotionally
motivationally and in terms of the
damage it does and so the involuntary
imposition of a threat is stressful and
damaging
but the voluntary acceptance of a threat
is invigorating and revivifying
two different spirits that's a good way
of thinking about it you know i and i
this might be a little bit off topic but
you're talking about young men and and
suffering we have seen in the orthodox
church and are seeing an increasing
influx of young men into orthodoxy and
what we find that they say is that this
is a form of christianity that
challenges them as men because it gives
them a fight that orthodoxy is about
asceticism it's about fasting in season
it's about overcoming the self the great
saints are those who have overcome
themselves and maybe even given their
lives for the truth but um i find that
to be so much more exciting and
challenging for me rather than the
insipid social justice warrior forms of
christianity yeah well it's clearly the
case that the church is the modern
churches and this is probably most true
of protestantism but
and perhaps least true of the orthodox
at the present time is that churches are
asking far too little not in not far too
much the church should ask of you
everything and to make it easy to be a
believer is completely counterproductive
it's it's the most difficult thing to
manifest and to be a believer i mean to
manifest the faith necessary to confront
the iniquities of existence because
faith doesn't mean the willingness to
abide by doctrines that you regard as
untrue as we've described today it means
instead to risk yourself on the off
chance that if you confronted life
honestly you could thereby transcend the
suffering that's intrinsic in life and
that's faith right because you you can't
do this kierkegaard pointed this out
quite clearly which is why he believed
redemption was an individual enterprise
is that you cannot be supplied with
enough evidence to convince you that
forthright contact with reality is the
best path you have to stake your life on
finding out whether or not that's true
there's no way out of that now people
can guide by imitation right and by by
uh example
that's what the saints do let's say
well that's what christ did
let's say
that's what the martyrs and the
confessors of the communist bloc did and
some of these people are still alive and
it's just such a scandal to me that in
the west we've completely swept it under
the rug i was telling some of the crew
here before we started tonight that when
i was in hungary i interviewed a woman
named maria whitner maria fitner was
she's very old now but she was a hero of
the 1956 resistance to the soviet uh
solid invasion this young woman took a
gun and went into the street to fight
the soviets and she suffered for it in
prison horribly but she's tough as nails
and would do it again these people are
still among us today jordan i met a
bunch of people in eastern europe people
in estonia for example who were heroes
of the anti-soviet movement some of them
from the time they were very little kids
as you pointed out people who are both
unbelievably tough in ways that people
in the west can hardly imagine
and also
characterized by that piece that you
described earlier you know this sort of
pro because they've been through things
so bad that the normal vicissitudes of
life seem like uh outright pleasures by
comparison you know i i dedicated my
book to the memory of a catholic priest
named father thomas love kolakovic and
he's an important figure not only of his
own time but an import profit for our
time and i'll tell you why
in 1943 father kalakovich was living in
zagreb in croatia his home country doing
work against the nazis in the
underground he got a tip that the
gestapo was coming for him so he escaped
the country went to his mother's home
country slovakia and began teaching at
the catholic university in bratislava he
told his students i have good news and
bad news for you the good news is the
germans are going to lose this war the
bad news is the soviets are going to be
ruling this country when it's over and
the first thing they're going to do is
come after the church we have to be
ready so what he did was put together
these small groups of catholic students
to pray but not just to pray but to talk
about very seriously what was happening
in the world around them and to make
concrete plans for how to act to get
ready for what was coming within two
years of that man coming to that country
these small groups existed all over the
country in a network to prepare for
living in the underground to prepare for
persecution now here's an interesting
thing
so he confronted that straight on yeah
yeah he did and he knew what was coming
because he had studied in seminary the
soviet mindset because he wanted to be a
missionary to the soviet union here's
the interesting thing
the catholic bishops of slovakia hated
him doing this he was scaring people
they said yeah yeah it's never gonna
happen here you know calm down father
but he didn't calm down he kept working
sure enough everything happened just
like he said when the iron curtain fell
over that country they came after the
church the reason that the underground
church was so strong in slovakia is
because this visionary priest father
kalakovich saw what was coming and he
gathered people around him to form
groups to prepare i believe jordan very
firmly that we are living in a kolakovic
moment in the west today and the
visionary christians and not even
christians people who want can
understand who can read the signs of the
times and who have courage whether
they're jewish muslim or of no faith at
all
need to understand what's happening and
start coming together now to prepare
this is part of the message that these
people yeah well ron
one of the things that i'm planning to
do is to make a video sometime in the
near future
it's preposterous and presumptuous of me
to do it but i'll probably do it anyways
and that's a message to the christian
church
and that is
and it's very much in keeping with what
you just described
the church should be reaching out to
young men
it should be saying very
straightforwardly and and i mean in the
most straightforward sense
your
noble ambitions
are welcome and necessary here
you can come in and help us clean up our
mess
we can help you clean up your mess and
we can move forward stalwartly and
confidently into the future
and i think the time for that is right
because there is no institution
there is no institution at the moment
that overtly welcomes young men
it's quite the contrary it says well
you're part of the patriarchal
oppression you're a despoiler of the
planet your ambition should be squelched
maybe your sexuality itself is
counterproductive
and so the churches have this great
opportunity to say
hey uh they don't want you
we'll take you
and maybe we can muddle through this
together or you can help revivify the
institution moribund as it always has
been and always will be and we can give
your youthful vision and enthusiasm some
traditional guidance there's a there's a
moment here that could be gripped by
well i hope the orthodox manage it i'd
like to see the catholics and the
protestants do it too i would too
because we're all in this again this is
one interesting thing i learned from
this research
is that uh the people who went to prison
the christians who went to prison
realized when they were there that they
weren't there because they were
catholics they weren't there because
they were orthodox or protestant they
were there because they were christians
and they formed bonds of fellowship that
reached across
lines of confessional lines in a similar
way i learned in prague from camilla
bendeva who is the wife of thoughts love
been to one of the the inner circle
around vatsalapal
she told me that even though she and her
husband were very conservative catholics
they had no trouble at all working with
the hippies hovel and the other hippies
who had no religious faith and led
really complicated sex lives they had no
trouble working with them because these
people had courage and that was the
rarest quality you ever found under
totalitarianism courage and uh the most
christians she said to me
kept their heads down and conformed
because they didn't want trouble but she
knew that she and her husband were
better off allying with those who did
not share their politics necessarily and
did not share their religion but who did
have courage i feel the same way about
what's happening in our country this is
why i would rather stand in the in the
foxhole with barry weiss a secular
liberal uh jewish lesbian or bretton
heather uh brett weinstein heather hein
who are atheists and on the left and
others who don't share my religious or
political convictions but who have shown
courage i feel the same way about
dawkins
yeah and harris for that matter
yeah
because the the thing that we all face
now is greater than what divides us we
have got to stop this before it it
triumphs and i think yeah
two things on that front i think that
the same might be said
on the abrahamic front is that the
traditionalists jews christians and
muslims should
recognize very rapidly that they have a
lot more in common than than they have
at the moment
dividing them and that the system of
ideas that we're talking about and not
necessarily those who carry the ideas
but the system of ideas that we're
talking about
is an enemy that's of such greater
magnitude than these internecine
conflicts that they're not even in the
same conceptual camp and so there's an
opportunity on that front as well
so well we can get our act together
notice that we worship the same god and
are all flawed enough not to be able to
interpret that with a hundred percent
accuracy
yeah and you know who some of them the
bravest people in the uk standing up to
wokeness are muslim parents who don't
want this right right kids in the
schools i'll tell you another story um a
few years ago in california
after a burgerfeld legalized gay
marriage
there was a bill filed in the california
legislature by the head of the lgbt
caucus that would take away cal grants
from so-called bigot schools these are
direct grants to under
privileged impoverished students who
could use them at any school in
california public or private
that was accredited well this bill would
have taken away the possibility of using
them at religious schools it would have
affected disproportionately poor black
and hispanic kids well
a friend of mine who's part of the
christian university system there tried
to get a group of
administrators to go around to the big
churches in orange county the white
evangelical mega churches to say this is
going to destroy a lot of christian
colleges in this in the state force them
to violate their conscience or shut down
we've got to fight this he told me that
not one of those mega churches those
white rich republican mega churches
would take this stand because they were
afraid of being called bigots the reason
that bill got defeated in the
legislature was black pentecostal
pastors of south central l.a and the
latino catholic archbishop of los
angeles so we are seeing immigrant
communities who are not buffaloed and
bullied by the woke who are willing to
stand up if we will just listen to them
yep yep well so i've been talking today
for all of those who are listening with
rod drear about his newest book live not
by lies
i would say inspired by the writings of
the great alexander solzhenitsyn we've
been talking about
the battle of ideas that is currently
dividing and threatening not only the
west but the entire world and what we
might all do as individuals and really
as individuals to
to wander away from the path that leads
to hell
and the proposition before us is
something like
at minimum
cease to say things that you believe to
be untrue cease to act in ways that you
know to be wrong
start with that
and perhaps
pick up your damn cross and carry it
uphill something like that right
forthrightly and nobly and that's really
the pathway out of this if
totalitarianism is the some consequence
of individuals willingness to abdicate
their responsibility and lie and i think
we've learned that in the aftermath of
the communist catastrophe and the nazi
experiments i think we've learned that
now if we applied it maybe we could
avoid doing the same thing again
i guess we're going to find out
yeah you know jordan uh you'll remember
that solzhenitsyn said in gulag
archipelago that if you had gone to all
the nice liberal intellectuals of 1890s
russia and said to them that within 30
years medieval tortures would be
reintroduced into russia they wouldn't
have believed it they would have thought
it was absolutely impossible well in a
similar way if you had gone
40 years ago to liberals in north
america and said that within 30 40 years
we were going to see
the sort of things that are being done
to children in the name of
transgenderism and we would see uh
people who are are clearly men being
described by police departments as women
and so on and so forth or else
but here we are
yeah yeah so okay so for everyone who's
listening i have uh recently inked a new
deal with the daily wire
dailywireplus.com and part of that is to
continue these discussions with my
guests uh for uh an additional period of
time behind the daily wire paywall and
that might be annoying to some of you uh
c'est la vie part of it is an attempt to
foster the daily wire wires growth and
part of it is also to provide me with
the opportunity to
have a hosting system let's say for my
content that isn't as
prone to the vagaries of the new woke
doctrines and so
i would encourage you to continue
listening to my conversation with rod
rare on dailywireplus.com